voilà donc père d'olivier marchal dans
un cinéma près de chez vous un parti
obuts
joue
l'enrichir vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment je me demande quelles questions
vous avez posé lorsque vous regardez le
matin dans un miroir vous dites quoi
qu'est-ce que je me matin je me demande
si je vais me raser ou pavoisés moi j'ai
envie d'avoir la barbe comme ça et puis
après je me rase les cheveux ça ne m'a
pas dit vous auriez aimé ressembler à
qui confier petit il monte en voilà
elise presley patricia de 20 à katyn et
c'est vrai vous ai pleuré quand pour la
dernière fois la mort de mon père vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
si je lui ai dit je me mettrais vraiment
facilement 40 cm de plus je me mettrais
décès que pour ça
richard quel est le péché qui vous tente
le plus j'aime bien manger
j'adore manger mais manger que vu que la
luxure non ça vous démange
oui c'est plus fort que vous oui c'est
marrant mais ça me démange tout le temps
voir un docteur
que pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif
sur vous depuis négatif parfois puis je
suis mal d'acteurs lit souvent quand je
me voyais pas bon tu trop petit on est
trop gros
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal si si on doute aussi on met en cause
mais ça c'est ma sincérité je m'en fous
si votre vie était à refaire que
changeriez quoi j'apprendrai
j'apprendrai plus en plus à l'école et
plus je sais pas j'aime pas je prendrai
aussi à danser à chanter sculpté violon
du piano fin tout jeune il ya plein de
choses que j'aurais aimé faire que j'ai
déclarent faire
qu'avez-vous le plus envie d'épater le
public et public n'est pas mon cas
j'aimerais aller il parlait parlait pas
de vous un quand le téléphone sonne vous
êtes heureux ou agacé ouais ouais je
vous ai passé quatre ans un peu comme ça
donc à l'hommage téléphone sonne et
ouais ah oui ma mère m'appelle tous les
jours que pleurer vous s'il vous restait
24 heures à vivre les bas je passerai 24
heures avec ma famille à quel est le
surnom au thon boutonne que vous haïssez
le plus on donne un seul surnom c'est
ricardo et je ne l'aï pas et puis j'ai
pas dit sur nous ouais ils disent pas
devant vous qu'avez-vous fait que nous
ne sachions pas tu faisais locarno en
stop
ouais c'était l'époque où tu étais
complètement fou les années 70 voilà
richard de quelques questions aimeriez
vous avoir la réponse
j'aimerais pas avoir les réponses ce que
c'est c'est bien comme ça c'est le
charme de 10 trucs c'est justement qu'on
ne sait pas et puis on voit là qu'est ce
que la vie vous a après je sais pas
l'amour ouais avez vous une meilleure
opinion de vous qu'à l'âge de 20 ans oui
oui je me sens mieux maintenant qu'à 20
ans nathan j'étais vraiment à bannu est
comme ma pomme tim jarry non si j'avais
quoi non non mais à quoi
reconnaissez-vous infailliblement la
bêtise j'étais si tranquille sur cette
réponse je vais très blonde et je ne
sais pas quoi jette répondre à mes
lunettes de soleil dans un restaurant
bagouet s'il a une canne par contre
bien qu'elle est votre expression
favorite je vais vous dire une
expression que je déteste
bah oui ça va alors l'expression que je
déteste qu'on entend tout le temps en ce
moment c'est sale fait moi aussi c'est
pas possible
là aussi je la déteste cette expression
il ya c'est clair aussi que les doubles
c'est clair ça le fait bien mieux qu'à
insupportable c'est demain qu'il y faut
ça fait juste trois ans qu'on se connaît
juste les gens mettent juste à tout
l'euro alors ouais c'est clair ça juste
sacré richard si un génie vous proposez
d'exaucer un chou et ça serait quoi ça
le fait grave c'est un souhait la mesure
est donc la rente centimètres de plus
salut travail de danser et chanter à
voir la boîte frank sinatra on s'excite
ya une cape et volé
les jambes